let's talk a little bit about the
pandemic we are embroiled right now
in a battle between coronavirus vaccines
and something known as the delta coveted
variant we're also going to talk more
about the delta variant on today's
bonus show we have an extraordinarily
strong situation here in the united
states
against the virus as i will show you
shortly but there are
real warning signs globally right now
which signal that unless we keep
vaccinating and really vaccinate more
people more quickly
we could be in a real problematic
situation
very soon within a couple of months so
let me walk you through it at first
glance
if you look at u s covid cases you see
that cases have dropped now more than 95
percent
from the pandemic high of about 255 000
cases a day
now down to about 11 000 cases a day
that is a massive reduction more than 95
when you look at covet deaths in the
united states
you also see really strong numbers in
fact
deaths are down more than 91 percent
from their pandemic high
of more than 3 400 per day to just
300 deaths per day now these are
fantastic numbers we are getting down to
what we would call like
baseline flu level risk
now when you look globally it still
looks good but it's not quite as good
and what i mean by that is that while
globally cases are still down
they're decreasing more and more slowly
global cases peaked around 830 000
we're now down about 56 percent to about
470
000 global coveted cases per day but if
you're
looking at the charts that we're
displaying here you'll see the decline
is leveling out it's a decline but it's
a slower and slower
decline and similarly on global deaths
we see deaths are now
down globally about 44 from their peak
but just in the last few days
that decline has also started to slow
down a little bit
so what's happening here what's driving
this what's happening
is that a more contagious by about 60
percent variant
called the delta variant is spreading
quickly in some countries
this variant as we talked about last
week with dr rasheesh
jah this is a variant that not only
spread 60
more quickly it's becoming dominant if
we look at cases in the united
kingdom cases are going up
now this is not cases are going down but
more slowly
we are actually seeing an increase in
cases in the united kingdom they were
down to
under 2 000 new cases a day they're now
back up to almost 10
000 cases a day now you might see this
and say david this is no problem you
know why
because in the u.s we've vaccinated way
more people than in the united kingdom
so we don't have to worry and you would
be
100 wrong if you look at vaccination
rates by country
you see that the u.s has fully
vaccinated 45 percent of our population
and the uk has fully vaccinated more 47
of its population it is wrong to say we
don't have to worry about
delta because we vaccinated more people
we haven't
what's happening is that the delta
variant
is dominant in the uk already and in the
u.s it is not yet
dominant this variant started in india
60 of new cases in the uk are now the
delta variant
only 10 of new cases in the u.s are now
the delta variant
so what that means is we are simply
on a delay from what is happening in the
united kingdom now
let's be really really clear if you were
vaccinated
at least with the vaccines approved here
here pfizer
moderna or johnson and johnson you are
protected against the delta variant the
vaccines work
really well against the delta variant
the problem
is that 55 percent of the country has no
protection right now
and so when you say well our pool of
vaccinated people is half the country
and this variant spreads sixty percent
more easily
you are going to get more and more cases
among the unvaccinated but you will also
get more cases among the vaccinated
because
vaccination is not 100 it's just simple
math
if you have a vaccine that's 95
effective
when there aren't many cases around you
that five percent that's not protected
is less likely to get the virus if you
have a 95 percent effective vaccine and
there's a ton of cases around you
because of unvaccinated people
it's just statistically more likely you
will have an interaction
with an unvaccinated and possibly
infected person and you'll see more of
what are called
breakthrough cases never mind of course
that among the unvaccinated if something
is 60 percent more contagious
it's going to spread like wildfire among
the unvaccinated so this is now a race
if we can keep vaccinating maybe we can
suppress the delta variant better than
the uk
simply because we're behind where they
are
in terms of the spread of that variant
becoming dominant it's
uh you could say a geographical thing it
got to the uk first
sixty percent of their new cases are now
delta only ten percent of ours are
it's still here it's still spreading the
percentage of cases here that are delta
is growing
but we have the benefit of you know it
seems like it's probably a couple of
months
of time to get more and more people
vaccinated that's the fundamental battle
right now
i'd get vaccinated i did uh and if i
were you
i would do the exact same thing let's
now talk a little bit about the
evolution
of vaccine opposition globally